اعلن الجيش في النيجر تاييده لمجموعه
الحرس الرئاسي التي اطاحت برئيس البلاد
محمد بازوم وحذر مما سماه عواقب وخيمه لاي
تدخل عسكري قبل الانقلاب بادانات من الامم
المتحده والاتحاد الاوروبي والاتحاد
الافريقي وعدد من الدول بين الولايات
المتحده وفرنسا بينما دعت روسيا طرفين
اذاعه النيجر الرحي خلافهما بالحوار على
حد قويها
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم كان ذكاء خبر حلقتنا ولنا في
نقاشه ثلاثه مسارات ما هي السياقات التي
قادت الى وقوع انقلاب عسكري في النيجر بعد
فشل اخر قبل عامين وكيف بدت مواقف الدول
التي تملك مصالح مباشره فيها من الانقلاب
وكيف ستتعاطى واشنطن وموسكو والدول
الافريقيه المجاوره مع نتائج هذا الانقلاب
بالنظر لتاثيره المحتمل على موازين القوى
الدوليه في منطقه غرب ووسط افريقيا كذلك
ما هي المسارات التي يمكن ان تاخذها
الاوضاع في غربي ووسط افريقيا على ضوء
صراع المصالح المحتدم بين القوى الدوليه
الكبرى على النفوذ في المنطقه وتنامي
اهتمامها بها
[موسيقى]
بعد عامين وثلاثه اشهر من اداء الرئيس
المدني المنتخب في النيجر محمد بزوم
اليمين الدستوريه خلفا لرئيس مدني منتخب
اخر في خطوه ظنها كثيرون نهايه للانقلابات
في هذا البلد الافريقي اعلنت مجموعه من
الحرس الرئاسي ايدها الجيش لاحقا
استيلاءها على السلطه في البلاد بسبب ما
سمته تدهور الوضع الامني وسوء الاداره
الاقتصاديه في البلاد المجموعه التي حذرت
من ان اي تدخل عسكري خارجي قد يؤدي لعواقب
وخيمه لا يمكن السيطره عليها وجد تحذيرا
لفرنسا ودعتها لاحترام سياده النيجر على
خلفيه ما سماه المتحدث باسمها هبوط طائره
عسكريه فرنسيه صباح الخميس في مطار ميامي
رغم اعلانهم اغلاق المجال الجوي للبلاد
ومن جانبه رفض الرئيس بزوما الاعتراف
بالانقلاب وقال ان المكاسب التي تحققت سوف
يحميها المواطنون الذين يؤمنون بالحريه
والديمقراطيه بحسب تعبيره
[موسيقى]
ولمناقشات هذا الموضوع معنا من ابو جاد
ديفيد دوتو مدير مركز جينيف للامن
والدراسات الاستراتيجيه في افريقيا من
ولايه كارولاينا الشماليه دكتور كامل
هاتسن كبير الباحثين في المركز الافريقي
في المجلس الاطلسي ومسؤول سابق في وزاره
الخارجيه الامريكيه من موسكو معنى الباحث
والمحلل السياسي رولاند
اهلا وسهلا بكم جميعا فيما وراء الخبر
ابدا معك سيد ديفيد اوتو اذا عندما وصل
محمد بازون للسلطه عام 2021
وتسلمها من رئيس مدني منتخب اخر
وبعد يعني قبل التنصيب بيومين كانت هناك
محاوله انقلاب فاشله ولكن رغم ذلك اعتقد
كثيرون ان النيجر قد غادر محطه الانقلابات
هل تفاجا هل كانت احداث السابع والعشرين
من يوليو مفاجاه
صوت
لا اسمع
للاسف
لم اكن اسمع ظهر ان هناك مشكله في الصوت
سنحاول حلها على العموم
لاتحول الى ضيفي من كارلان الشماليه
كاميرون
يعني اذا توقفنا عندما قاله قائد المجموعه
الانقلابيه قال ان ما حدث كان نتيجه
لسببين اولا الوضع الامني
المتدهر وايضا سوء الاداره الاقتصاديه هي
نفس المبررات التي ساقها الانقلابيون في
افريقيا الوسطى وفي مالي كذلك وفي بوركينا
فاسو ما واجهت هذين السببين
في الحقيقه اعتقد اننا نتحدث عن تبريرات
وانا لا اعرف لماذا يجب ان اخذ بعين
الاعتبار القياده العسكريه فيما تقوله وهي
قد اطاحت بحكومه منتخب ديمقراطيه بكل واضح
نحن نتحدث عن سياسات داخليه في النيجر
ولنتحدث عن تنافس القوى الكبرى وطبعا لا
نتحدث عن سوء اداره الاموال العامه ان
حكومه بازون كانت شريكا وطيضا مع واشنطن
وباريس وبروكسيل وكانت حكومه جيده تحصل
على مساعدات في مجال التنميه وفي المجالات
الماليه وكانت تعزز المبادئ الديمقراطيه
والشفافيه وبالتالي اذا ما كان الجيش
يعارض كل هذه الامور وطبعا من الواضح انهم
يعرضون ذلك ها هم ياتون بتبريرات للاطاحه
بالحكومه بحسب فهمي يرتبط بالسياسات
الخاصه سياسات القبليه الداخليه في النيجر
بالاضافه الى التوترات في داخل القوات
المسلحه ولكن الامر لا يرتبط بسوء اداره
الاموال وسوء اداره البلاد نعم هناك
تحديات متعدده في النيجر شانها شان بلدان
اخرى الفقر الارهاب الى اخره ما من شك بان
التحديات كبيره في وجه هذه الاداره
والادارات الاخرى في البلدان الافريقيه
ولكنها ليست الطريقه المناسبه للتعامل مع
هذه التحديات
يعني في هذا الاطار كان الجميع ربما
يعتقدون ان الامور قد استقرت في النيجر
بسبب هذا التسلم السلمي للسلطه مره اخرى
هل تفاجا المراقبون بهذه الخطوه التي حدثت
في 27 يونيو
لا اعتقد ان الامر كان مفاجاه ما كان
ينبغي ان يكون مفاجاه فان احد الامور
التي
حاولت الدول غرب افريقيا ان تعطي اشارات
تنبيه ومبكر كانت توقع عن هذه المؤشرات
التي ظهرت
بحصوله احتمال حصول انقلاب عسكري كان
ينبغي معالجتها منذ زمن بعيد طبعا هذه
كانت حكومه جاءت الى السلطه عن طريق
صناديق الاقتراع والان
طاح بها بالرصاص الطلقات حسب خبرتي ان هذه
المنطقه ان هناك دائما
تقليد او تكتيكات او اساليب لتقليد ما
قامت به دول اخرى فمثلا من جهه تقع ضمن
منطقه خطيره جدا حيث
انقلابات سابقه وهي الدول المجاوره
وبالتالي كان من المحتمل جدا انه بعد
بعد اخفاق
في المحاوله الانقلاب اللي عند تسليم
السلطه كانت هذا اشاره الى ان حكومه
نيجيريا كان يجب ان تعلم
والكواس ايضا كان ينبغي يعرف ان هناك شيء
ما يجري اعداد له ولكن ما هو مستوى
العرقيه والخلافات القبائليه المجرده داخل
صفوف الجيش او الحكومه لكن ما اعرفه على
وجه التاكيد هو هناك مستوى مصلحه كبيره
لدى العسكريين في المنطقه ليستولوا على
السلطه للكثير من هؤلاء السياسيين يعتمدون
على العسكريين والعسكريين يرون هذه ميزه
لهم ولكن مره اخرى اعتقد كان هذا افضل
الوقت بالنسبه للعسكريين ليقوموا بمقام
ابوه في النيجر لانه بدعم من دول مثل
بوركينا فاسو ومالي
ولابد ان نضيف ايضا انه اكوس اي محاوله من
عزله جمهوريه
الى موضوع ردود فقط لتعزيز ما قلته بشان
عدم تفاجا رئيس محمد بازون ربما هناك كان
حديث عن محاوله لاقاله رئيس الحرس الرئاسي
او قائد الحرس الرئاسي قبل فتره وجيزه من
وقوع هذا الانقلاب على العموم فقط نتوقف
عند ردود الفعل على ما حصل فمثلا
مصدر دبلوماسي في مجلس الامن الدولي اكد
الجزيره ان المجلس سيعقد الجمعه جلسه
مشاورات مغلقه
لمناقشته الامم المتحده دانت بشده ما سمته
التغير غير الدستوري للحكومه في النيجر
ودعت لاطلاق سراحه الرئيس بازو الموقف
ذاته عبر عنه رئيس الاتحاد الافريقي الذي
دعا منظمه الاكواس والافارقه والمجتمع
الدولي لرفض ما يجري في النيجر منظمه اكوس
لم تتاخر من جانبها في ادانه ما وصفته
بمحاوله السيطره على السلطه بالقوه في
النيجر باشد العبارات واشنطن دانه
الانقلاب واكدت انها تدعم الرئيس بازون
بقوه بصفته رئيسا منتخبا بشكل ديمقراطي
وفي ذات الاتجاه جاء موقف فرنسا التي قالت
انها تدين اي محاوله للاستيلاء على السلطه
بالقوه في النيجر وانها تراقب الوضع هناك
اما روسيا التي تستضيف قمه
القمه الروسيه الافريقيه
فيرج فدعت من سمتهم اطراف النزاع في
النيجر لحل المسائل دون استخدام القوه اذا
هنا السؤال للسيد رونالد بيجاموس
واضح ان هناك اختلاف في رد الفعل الروسي
عن بقيه المواقف
روسيا لا تعتبر ما حدث في النيجر الانقلاب
تعتبره نزاع بين
طرفين يمكن حله
ما دلاله هذا الموقف
ولماذا ما الذي استندت اليه روسيا في هذا
التحليل
سؤال انا اعتقد ان روسيا تنطلق من مباديها
من مبادئ السياسه الخارجيه الروسيه
العقيده الدبلوماسيه الروسيه تقول انها هي
ضد التدخل في الشونه الداخليه فلذلك في
مثل هذه الحالات الروسيه دائما تاخذ هذا
الموقف مع ذلك لابد من التاكيد ان هذه
الحاله قد تصايد على روسيا الى كسب النقاط
في هذه المنطقه على غرار ما حدث في
سنترالا فريك
وكذلك في جمهوريه مالي
ولكنه يجب القول ان السبب الرئيسي لهذا
الانقلاب هو بطبيعه الحال
العامل الداخلي الاسباب الداخليه والوضع
الاقتصادي ولكن مع ذلك يجب ان نعترف انه
هناك
نوع من التفير من الجوار الجيو استراتيجي
غير
المستقر وايضا لا بد من القبول ان تصادف
هذا الانقلاب مع قمه روسيا افريقيا في سنه
لا يدل ان هناك اي علاقه مباشره بين امرين
في كل حال من الاحوال
اعتقد انهم منا السابق لابوانه ان نتحدث
اليوم انا روسيا ستدخل بالقوه في هذه
الدوله الا رغم من ان هناك كانت مظاهرات
اليوم
مشجعه للدور الروسي في افريقيا ولكن انا
اعتقد شخصيا نعم تقول ستدخل بقوه في هذه
الدوله وهذا
النيجر وضح كلامك
التايمز البريطانيه ووجه سؤالي لديفيد
اوتو صحيفه التايمز كانت تعتقد في اكتوبر
الماضي يعني قبل اكثر من تسعه اشهر ان
الدوله الثانيه التاليه التي ستخسرها
فرنسا في افريقيا
لصالح روسيا ستكون النيجر هل تحققت
النبوءه الان هل هذا ما يحدث الان
في الواقع هناك امكانيه لا يعرفها بالضبط
لحد الان ان حول ان اي بلد يمكن ان نخبه
هذه الانقلاب العسكري ان ينظموا اليها او
ينحازوا اليها لكن من تحدثت اليهم عن
الارض في نيجيريا اوضحوا لي بشكل لا لبسه
فيه بان هناك اختلاف او موقف لمناهض
للفرنسيين في البلاد تتذكرون فرنسا كانت
قد نشرت بعض قواتها من عمليه القانون
كانوا في مال سابقا وهذه القوه نقلت الى
نيجير وبالتالي بالوضع الحالي
باستلام السلطه من
الجيش اسلام السلطه منها حكومه وانتخبه
الديمقراطيه التي كانت فرنسا تدعمها هناك
احتمال كبير ان اخر معقل
لفرنسا في افريقيا قد ضعها من يدها
وبالتالي نعم هذه اخبار سيئه لفرنسا ولكن
لا نعرف الواقع بشكل مؤكد من الذي سيحل
محلها ومن سياتي هل ساعدتكم فرصه لروسيا
للتدخل والتعزيز
تواجدها في في ظهوريه النيجر ولكن ايضا
هنا خلاعب كبير جدا في في النيجر وهناك
قدراتك عسكريه كبيره وبالتالي من سابق
لاوانه ان نعرف لكن ما نعرفه فعلا انه حصل
تغيير في النظام
والسؤال التالي هو هو من هي الدوله
التاليه بعد ذلك من الذي سيدخل لملا
الفراغ الذي يمكن ان تحدثه فرنسا هنا بهذا
الانقلاب
طبعا
كثيرون يتوقعون ان تكون روسيا هي هذه
الدوله
واشنطن ما الذي يمكن ان تفعله اذا هذا
يعني رده الفعل الان هي تدين وتطالب
المنقلبون ان يتراجعوا ولكن فعليا ماذا
تستطيع واشنطن ان تفعل
في الحقيقه اعتقد انا واشنطن سوف تستخدم
اوراق الضغط التي لديها حيث ان الولايات
المتحده الامريكيه هي اكبر مانح للنيجر
مئات الملايين من الدولارات تقدم في
مساعدات تنمويه وغذائيه
ولمكافحه التغير المناخي بالاضافه الى كل
المساعده الامنيه والعسكريه التي كانت
تحصل عليها النيجر لذلك واشنطن لديها دورا
كبير تؤديه في كل ذلك سوف تحاول ان تستخدم
هذه الاوراق ولكن هذه
الوصفه
ولم تنجح في افريقيا الوسطى ما الذي
يجعلها تنجح في النيجر
ليس بلدا مثل هذه البلدان لديه حكومه
منتخبة ديمقراطيا وهو شريك وثيق لواشنطن
بالنسبه الى بوركينا فاسو ومالي نتحدث عن
بلدين اصلا كان خارج
الفضاء الغربي وهناك مشاعر مناهضه للغرب
في البلدين الوضع يختلف بشكل جذريا في
النيجر نعم هناك الكثير من التحديات
المشابهه ولكن الناس كانوا يحاولون ان
يتقدموا باتجاه الديمقراطيه على
يهز راسه بضراوه يعني نتحدث عن فعلا تاثير
حقيقي ممكن ان يحدثه تدخل الامريكي ما
تعليقك
انا لا اتفق معه بان بان النيجر مختلفه عن
ما حصل في بوركينا فاسو مالي
اعتقد ان السؤال الكبير الذي يساله سيسالك
الكثير من الناس هو لماذا رغم الكميات
كبيره من اموال التي انفقتها الولايات
المتحده في نيجر فلماذا هذه الجمهوريه
انتهى بها المطاف
انقلاب عسكريه هذا هو السؤال الكبير الذي
ينبغي على المسؤولين في واشنطن ويساله حول
ما يحصل وبالتالي لا اعتقد انه السيناريو
مختلف فيها هنا لو نظرنا الى الى الى
سكان
الايجار فاننا نرى نشاهد تغير كبير كامل
في القياده
كانت على تاثير كبير من الدول الغربيه ما
نراه هنا وليس لا شيء لا شيء يختلف عم ا
شاهدناه في حاله مالي وبوركينا فاسو
واعتقد وانا اخشى انه ربما ان الولايات
المتحده الصفقه الكثير نفوذها لو انا قاده
الانقلاب قرروا ان يبحثوا عن شركاء خارج
الولايات المتحده ومن غير من الدول الاخرى
وهنا اتوجه للرولاند بجامه اذن
الانظار تتوجه
نحو موسكو وخصوصا بعد الرد الفعل الذي
سمعناه وما الذي يمكن ان تفعله خلال
الفتره القادمه خصوصا وان هناك انطباع
ربما تولد لدى خصوم روسيا بان روسيا ليس
لديها مانع ان تساند وتدعم حكام
ديكتاتوريين مقابل ان تستغل ثروات بلاد
افريقيه مختلفه
كيف يمكن فعلا لموسكو ان تتعامل مع هذا
الموقف
والانطباع الموجود
في رايه على متوازيه قصه النيجر بنسبه
لروسيا هي بمثابه غيمه بمطر لا تستفيدوا
روسيا كثيرا من التركيز على هذا البلد
ولكن انطلاقا من مبدا النديه يمكنها
لروسيا ان تتدخل
وتدعم الحكومه التي
ستكون في السلطه في هذا البلد ربما سيكون
هناك تكرار سيناريو مالي وسيناريو
الافريقيا الوسطه ولكن في كل حال من
الاحوال فرنسا ستحافظ بدورها والغرب بشكل
عام لان ما نشهده اليوم في المالي روسيا
روسيا تشارك فقط في المجال الامن ولكن
باريس تحافظ على مواقفها في اقتصاد البلاد
وفي قطاع الاعمال وايضا هناك
المخاوف من الدوره الصيني ومن المنافسه
الصينيه اللي انا الصين تريد ان تشاركوا
في استخراج اليورانيوم ربما
من من
والكبيره
النيجر واسالك كاميرنه هاتسن يعني اذا
كانت فرنسا تعتمد على اليورانيوم بنسبه
كبيره يورانيوم النيجر تحديدا لانتاج 70%
من كهربائها
انقطاع هذا المورد بلا شك سيكون له تاثير
كبير فكيف يمكن ان تتعامل فرنسا واوروبا
بشكل عام مع ما يجري مع انقطاع هذا اوروبا
والغرب مع انقطاع هذا المولد
اعتقد اننا شاهدنا ان فرنسا ارسلت طائره
اليوم الى النيجر في محاوله لاجلاء
الرئيسي بازوم اعتقد ان التحدي
للدول هو انه عندما نشاهد انقلابا يكون
هناك عز لا دبلوماسيه وعقوبات واجراءات
عقابيه في البلدان المختلفه واعتقد انه ما
رايناه في السابق لم نتبع هذه المعادله
وبالتالي القاده الذين قادوا هذا الانقلاب
لا يخشون التبعات ولذلك يستمرون في انتاج
نفس السلوك وبالتالي واشنطن وباريس
وبروكسيل في موقف صعب يحاولون فيه ان يسلط
الضوء على اهميه قيم الديمقراطيه على
الامد البعيد وفي المدى القريب الامن في
هذه البلدان طبعا على الامد الب هناك
مشاكل وتحديات في حال لم يكن هناك اتساق
في فرضي
النتائج
ومعاقبه دقيقتين سامحني ساقاطعك هنا انت
تتحدث عن الديمقراطيه والحريات التي يعت
بها الغرب وسؤال السيد من جهه وهناك طبعا
معادله الامن التي تعد بها روسيا فكيف
يمكن ان توازن دوله مثل النيجر بين هذين
وما هو المستقبل والسيناريوهات المحتمله
وخصوصا بعد ما حصل هناك
اعتقد انه ما يتعلق بجانب الامني حتى
روسيا عليها ان تتصرف بحذر كبير نظرا
للوضع الذي
يواجهه ما يسمى بالتمرد لاقامه
على روسيا ان تستطيع ان تعيد التفاوض اذا
ما ارادت ان تصلح مصدر ثقه بالنسبه للدول
الافريقيه وتعتبر ينظر اليها كشريك امني
معظم الدول الافريقيه لا تحب ان يكون
لديها قوه فاكنار منتشر على ارضها يكون
هناك
قوات نظاميه
وابدا يعتقد انه حتى لو ان روسيا كانت
مهتمه بتوسيع
نفوذها من ناحيه عسكريه في النيجر عليها
ان تفكر لان هذا الانقلاب قد يكون احد
نتائج
للاسف مضطر للمقطاعتك ديفيد اوتوم مدير
مركز جنيف للامن ودراسات الاستراتيجيه في
افريقيا من ابو جوى شكرا لك من ولا يه
كارولانا الشماليه كبيره الباحثين في
المركز الافريقي في المجلس الاطلسي مسؤول
سابق في وزاره الخارجيه الامريكيه ومن
موسكو الباحث والمحلل السياسي رونالدز
شكرا لكم مشاهدينا على متابعه هذه الحلقه
[موسيقى]